it was soon apparent that a trip to the
poles in the ugandan capital of kampala
would require a serious amount of time
some polling stations opened two hours
late
and the computers on site were acting up
but the voters took their place in
ever-lengthening queues
hoping their ballots completed in the
bottom of washing up tubs
would make the difference what's going
through your mind
okay what's going to make just change
change
we need change enough is enough
the election campaign which kicked off
in november
was contentious and violent but that
hasn't put off the electorate
many of whom seem determined to rid the
country of its long-time
leader yuri maseppen
and a former pop star turned politician
bobby wine
has fired up millions of younger voters
with a call for political revolution
this is the day when we take the first
major step into a new uganda
okay yeah do you think that could happen
that will happen
yeah doesn't matter how long
it takes doesn't matter how much stress
we have to go through
we know we are going to be free
oppressed people cannot be oppressed
forever
his vehicle was mobbed as it approached
the polling station
a would-be president with a rock star
following
you know this is probably the easiest
campaign appointment
he's had to make over the last couple of
months no one's shooting at him
and there isn't any tear gas but that
doesn't mean he's on the brink of
winning the presidency
the odds are not in bobby wine's favor
museveni has run this country since 1986
and he will not step aside from mr wine
instead the president signaled his
readiness to continue
casting his vote in the knowledge that
he's backed by
the state his administration has turned
the internet off
and government officials have organized
the poll
there are other options for the
presidency like the only female
candidate
nancy kalembe she thinks museveni should
step down
but she doesn't want bobby wine to
replace him
it's expected that when you come on to
the political scene and you're running
for presidency the first thing you do is
you have to insult president museveni
every day
that's not dignified are you saying that
bobby wine is creating noise
and drama but not not substance to be
honest with you
i don't think bobby wine is presidential
material at all
he's very undignified he's leading a
group of people who do not have
a lot of content it's about noise
the count has begun in uganda amid much
excitement
and anticipation but that could change
if the public
does not trust the result john sparks
sky news